hey there Garden enthusiasts today we're
going to dive into the world of growing
tomatoes in your own garden tomatoes are
a staple in many Gardens and for good
reason they're easy to grow and their
versatility in the kitchen makes them a
must have for any Gardener first let's
talk about planting tomatoes thrive in
well- drained soil so make sure to
prepare your garden bed accordingly
plant your tomato seeds or seedlings
about 18 in Ines apart and give them
plenty of space to grow next let's
discuss watering Tomatoes love water so
keep them well hydrated especially
during the hot summer months however be
careful not to overwater as this can
lead to root Rod growing tomatoes in a
small garden can be very rewarding and
is manageable with a bit of planning
here's a step by step guide to help you
get started one choose the right tomato
varieties compact or bush varieties look
for determinate or dwarf varieties like
patio princess Tiny Tim or bush Early
Girl these types are great for small
spaces as they don't grow as tall or
need much staking cherry or grape
tomatoes varieties like sweet 100 or sun
gold grow well in small spaces and
produce high yields to select the best
spot sunlight tomatoes need at least 6-
8 hours of direct sunlight each day take
the sunniest spot in your garden to
ensure good growth and fruiting wind
protection tomatoes are sensitive to
strong winds which can damage their
stems if your garden is windy plant near
a fence or at a Windbreak three prepare
the soil well drained rich soil Tomatoes
thrive in loose well- draining soil if
your garden soil is heavy or clay likee
mix in compost Pete Moss or aged manure
to improve it nutrient-rich min mix in a
balanced slow release fertilizer one
that includes nitrogen phosphorus and
pottassium or compost to provide a
nutrient boost for planting the tomatoes
timing plant after the last frost date
in your area tomatoes are warm season
plants and need consistently warm
temperatures spacing for small spaces
plant tomatoes about 18- 24 in apart
even if you're using dwarf varieties
this helps Ensure good air circulation
which reduces disease risk deep planting
plant tomatoes deeply varying to thirds
of the plant including some of the lower
leaves this helps the plant develop a
stronger root system finally let's talk
about fertilizing tomatoes are heavy
feeders so give them a good dose of
compost or fertilizer when you plant
them and then again every few weeks
throughout the growing season and there
you have it with these simple tips you
will be on your way to Growing delicious
tomatoes in your own garden thanks for
tuning in and don't forget to follow And
subscribe for more gardening tips and
tricks happy gardening